ok I got one I got one I I read an
article recently that talked about yeah
talked about the ways in which improv
Improv Theater or improv comedy could be
a useful tool to help dissolve or deal
with people suffering from anxiety
essentially improv what you think about
it allows you to step into the moment
and part of the reason that we suffer
ank this is we have we have this
neocortical hardware this overactive
amygdala neocortex not concerned with
the future and therefore hyper-vigilant
and therefore second-guessing anything
we might possibly want to do so instead
of living impulsively and free if
they're having a disposition of living
in the moment we are stuck with that
monkey mind second-guessing everything
the inner critic the interval T out and
it turns out that to be lunged into a
situation that you don't fully control
forces you to improvise but in being
forced to improvise you step into the
deep now and that silences the inner
critic the lateral prefrontal cortex the
self editor the self doubter gets
quieted the neuroscience of being in the
now silences the worrying future-focused
neocortex and this provides subjectively
a feeling of release and freedom so
people who are overly anxious writer do
improv
hitter and they're they're like wow I
don't even remember what I said well
that's part of the fun it's to lose
yourself to step outside yourself to be
yourself to trust to submit until we be
willing to be surprised because people
will claim they get on stage right there
GI and they're Jami and they're like you
I was so in the zone I don't even
remember what I said I didn't remember
what I did I don't even remember what
happened and then you watch it later and
it looks like they're channeling right
it comes through them but not from them
and though it is with them it belongs
not two of them right jazz musicians to
the zone athletes right in the pocket in
the runner in the runner's high this is
a magical thing right I think for me my
desire to make videos my desire to make
content my desire to capture inspiration
genuine inspiration is because when it
happens it erupts from within you it
happens in real time I start talking and
I don't know what I'm gonna say and when
I'm done after that cognitive
rollercoaster ride of associational
think I land somewhere I'm like holy
crap what just happened and to be able
to watch that people wait is that
playback then allows a part of myself to
see what's possible when I let go of my
fear and I let go of my doubt it's like
holy that's me
oh and so anyway that article about how
improv is a way to eliminate or deal
with anxiety made a lot of sense there's
a lot of science to that so yeah man
step out of your comfort zone be naked
get on stage and see what happens